en muy buenos días desde nueva york pues
sin duda el momento más destacado fue la
aceptación formal de la nominación como
candidato demócrata de haydn el
candidato lanzó su discurso desde
delaware un discurso en el que trató
todos los temas que interesan sobre todo
al partido y que pondrán en práctica que
aplicarán en los próximos cuatro años si
salen elegidos como presidente joe biden
entre ellos encontramos temas como
inmigración cambio climático economía y
también por supuesto la crisis sanitaria
que estamos viviendo yo wyden puso
encima de la mesa soluciones prácticas
como por ejemplo una norma nacional
sobre el uso de la mascarilla de pruebas
de kobe rápidas para detectar los
positivos en señora serie de soluciones
para acabar con esta crisis hubo otros
momentos muy destacados también como una
fórmula bastante interesante en la que
vimos a ciudadanos y líderes explicar
cómo se veían de aquí a un año por estas
mismas fechas con joe biden como
presidente vimos también un vídeo en el
que conocimos a un candidato de oferta
desde un punto de vista más personal
me mostraron como una persona empática
generosa que puede llegar a conseguir la
unión de este país vimos escuchamos a
sus hijos a sus nietos se rindió también
un homenaje a su fallecido hijo beau
biden que falleció con 46 años por un
cáncer de cabeza escuchamos también
antiguos rivales en estas primarias como
por ejemplo el senador por new york's y
por y brooke quien dijo que el apoyo de
joe biden a los derechos sindicales
acabaría con los estadounidenses con la
pobreza de algunos estadounidenses
vimos escuchamos también al senador
escuchamos también a la ex alcalde de la
ciudad de nueva york michael bloomberg
quien habló de economía y por supuesto
también destacar los reacciones por
parte del presidente de una trama a
través de su cuenta de twitter y en una
entrevista de 30 minutos con una
intervención telefónica en la cadena fox
mientras que se estaba celebrando la
convención demócrata